switching gears here to talk about our
nice and chilly weather outside yes
great thanksgiving evening oh man let me
tell ya people were out running biking
that's all i'm
saying get rid of that you know excess
and then you're gonna fill it up i can't
wait for seconds and thirds tonight
thirds and then you gotta walk around
the block a couple times oh forget that
then we go right into dessert
speaking of that guys i've got a flow
facts for you thanksgiving addiction
it's not how many calories we consume is
it no but that's a good idea no don't
tell us that we'll save that for later
okay all right flow facts
only male turkeys actually gobble
female turkeys do the cackling actually
i know that yeah i think i have an
ex-girlfriend that cackles
um black friday is said to be the
busiest day of the year for plumbers
with probably good reason well a lot of
the grease folks yes let's not think
about the other stuff but yeah my
like uncle sal eating too much and going
to the restroom yeah we'll put this on
social media for you to share with your
friends and family a lot of people are
asking for more flow facts so we're
putting them on there for you but a nice
evening guys we start off the morning on
the 40s so this time around not much of
a warm day today and a lot of you are
okay with that right temperatures
outside right now 56 sky canyon
centennial hills same for you up there
on providence 52 and spring valley i
want to wish a big thanksgiving to all
of you and they're at home right now
watching us we're on air for you 57 in
north las vegas 63 sunrise manor 61 for
uh whitney ranch and green valley 56
right now for henderson and mountains
edge and road ranch 58 50 frampton 52
from southern highlands right now got a
lot of eight news out viewers in
southern highlands and silverado ranch
want to give a big shout out to you 46
indian springs right now 58 up there in
northeast clark and mesquite 64 right
now for laughlin and death valley
checking in at 71 degrees so here's the
deal our wind advisory lake wind
advisory expired at 6 pm on the dot but
the santa ana winds continue
unfortunately for southern california
they have fire weather warnings they
have high
wind warnings right now while all
warnings and watches have all expired
clear skies out right now but you'll
notice some clouds coming in already
encroaching on the northern portions of
california we'll see some of those
clouds tomorrow mixing with some
sunshine but otherwise a mostly sunny
day for all your recreation there's a
lot of things going on and chad opens
guys tomorrow that's a good one you got
glittering lights 64 tomorrow so the
warming trend begins tomorrow that puts
us a few degrees above normal and then
look at this saturday and sunday closer
to 70 for those days that you have off
and those winds should stay light too
for those days too overnight lows here's
the big story the morning starts gonna
be a little chilly again for those
morning joggers that are trying to get
rid of that excess turkey talking about
the spare tire 41 for downtown in the
morning along with the lakes 38 for
someone 39 state rose parkway down to 41
for the east side then sunrise manor 40
for dallas outside of town 27. lee
county your morning start tomorrow 37 in
mesquite 50 for loftland so chilly in
the morning 42 degrees are low
officially chilly and clear lighter
winds after those gusts we had earlier
today 64 for tomorrow sunny and cool
tomorrow and great like we said for
recreation for your black friday eight
day forecast temperatures each day get
warmer we'll come close to records on
sunday unfortunately come close to
records again on wednesday unfortunately
but temperatures next week in the low
70s yes it's mild but really not too bad
but it is above average and i'll have
your recreation forecast coming up in
your weather now in just a couple
minutes here on 8 news now